let me ask you
uh one thing that a bunch of people are
curious about
you're one of the innovators first of
all you're one of the
great innovators and philosophers and
thinkers in jiu jitsu right
but you're also one of the innovators in
terms of leg locks
and and the 50 50 position and just like
the fact that legs have something to do
in jiu jitsu uh
the the other the other
popularizer innovator in the space is
john donahue and his whole group of guys
do you have um thoughts about their
whole system of leg locks and
their ideas about jiu-jitsu and so on
sure i i guess uh you know obviously you
know john and and the students at henzo
have been able to do fantastic things
competitively in the past number of
years and you know um
you mentioned innovators in the in that
kind of you know
section of jiu jitsu i would be uh i'd
love to bring up some
guys like dean lister um of course uh
masakazi minari in fact a lot of what
was going on
in like 90s japan like combat submission
wrestling there was some crazy gnarly
stuff that
it's just it's on grainy vhs tape but
like stuff that if people were doing now
they go oh my god that's brand new
like there's um it's it's been i think
these are things that have been around
for a while
um in various places i first learned the
50 50 position just like the leg
entanglement of it
from brandon vera actually at a seminar
at lord urban's martial arts i think in
2005.
he learned it from dean lister uh who
used it to submit
alexandria cocareco a really really
tough nogi guy at adcc
on the in the run that uh dean made to
the to the gold medal in the absolute
division which was a great performance
at the time first american to do that
um and uh you know and i actually saw a
video i mean first of all boss rutin
actually broke i think guy mesger's
foot with a 50 50 heel hooked he
actually grabbed his heel
and his and his toes and in pancreas
it's back when they had like the man
panties and the high uh
yeah and uh dude that was gnarly boss
rooting is underappreciated as like
as like he double oh grab like oh yeah
like you know his leveraged leverage
that's like a total that's
you know that goes the other way and
it's like it either doesn't work or
breaks in half and uh
well he's uh people don't often think of
bas rooting as an
innovator but he is in a way like
he uh you know talk about like elon musk
and first principles thinking in terms
of physics
he like just feels like he just gets the
job he figures out like the simplest way
to get the job done of breaking things
and
establishing control and hurting people
remember that was back in the day
if you listen to boss root and do any
like commentary for any of the uh the
big mma shows or any mma show way back
when any time guys were clinching like
the gosh roll for an ebar he was saying
that way back when and now people are
doing it
all the time with varying degrees of
success it's it's funny it's like it's
also tough to be
uh i think like a breakaway thinker i
mean you know groupthink is a real thing
in group inertia
and it's it's neat to see um you know
particularly
at a time when maybe that type of stuff
was less accepted
um you know someone going hey i'm gonna
i'm gonna run off in this other
direction i think you know whoever
you know the inventor of electricity in
my mind is a lot more impressive than
whomever not to say that the person down
the line isn't impressive that comes up
with an interesting way to use it
um both are cool but when you think
about
just them can you imagine we're sitting
here like yeah people i'm going to build
an airplane you're like what are you
talking about it's crazy people don't
fly
like no i'm going to do it and of course
it's not going to be as good as the
airplane down the line the iterative
things that happen later on
but um just being able to go to dream
something into existence that you
haven't seen before and then
make it happen like takes an
unbelievable like strength of character
almost like a force of will
because you have you're you're blazing a
trail that hasn't been
walked before that's the bj pen factor
in you know
winning the jiu jitsu world championship
first non-brazilian to do that what it
was back in 2001
and then rafael lovato later on it's
like he's you know both of those guys
are so unbelievably impressive in my
mind for the same reason you know
because they were
out there winning at a time when that
wasn't a common thing not that it's easy
to win now it's just
there's not a psychological hurdle that
needs to be left i remember you know
when i was early in jiu jitsu like
americans weren't winning the world
championships at any belt i mean
bj we all knew bj penn because bj penned
it but it was
really really uncommon now it happens
you know on a semi-regular basis of
course the brazilians are so strong
europeans are still strong
but uh and australians are coming on as
well but uh
it's definitely kind of an interesting
thing so to come back to
you know john danaher and the uh hensar
team obviously they're doing
fantastic things john's had some really
really great innovation there
and the the the systematization and the
methodology
that they're using is uh is great and
it's neat to see that it's getting out
there um i would just also
what i would encourage people to make
sure that they're you know catching up
on their history because obviously you
know john's a brilliant instructor and
has done things you know for the sport
that um that are fantastic they haven't
been done before
but you know none of us exist in a
vacuum and i've learned things from
everywhere else so you know john would
say the same i'm sure
and uh you know dean lister would say
the same and it's just neat when you can
kind of trace the history of all of this
happening because we've had
humanity's had two arms and two legs for
some time at least as long as i've been
alive
you